there is a man who spreads joy amongst
children once a year they lay awake and
eager anticipation of his arrival
what presence does he bring with him on
this evening the cookies have been baked
and the milk has been poured but as the
shadowy figure approaches their
excitement and joy turns into fear and
despair for this man is not Saint
Nicholas or Santa Claus or even father
Christmas
this man is no man at all this is
Krampus the shadow of Christmas and
tonight there will be no presence
received the half goat half demon figure
has often been described as the anti
Saint Nicholas but in some countries in
his belief that Krampus accompanies
Saint Nicholas during Christmas
punishing those children who have
misbehaved in contrast to Saint Nicholas
who rewards the well-behaved children
Krampus has been feared and celebrated
and folklore for hundreds of years and
his appearance is that of nightmares
with large barren horns dark hair sharp
fangs and a long pointed tongue he
carries around chains which are thought
to be symbolic of the Christian church
bind in the devil as well as these
chains
Krampus carries a bundle of birch sticks
used to swat misbehaving children Saint
Nicholas would reward the war behaved
children with gifts and presence and he
would leave the misbehaving children
with a lump of coal
this would signal to Krampus which
children were to be whipped and beaten
on occasion Krampus would throw
misbehaving children into his sack or
basket and take them down to his lair in
the underworld the depictions and
stories of Krampus do distinctly vary
and there is no definitive version
considered to be correct in some
illustrations he's more Monster than man
and in others he appears as half man
half demon
unlike Saint Nicholas the origins of
Krampus appear to be a little bit more
unclear the earliest tales of Krampus do
appear to have originated from the
Austrian Alps and Germany perhaps even
predate in Christianity the word Krampus
is derived from the German crampon
meaning claw and we do see Krampus share
characteristics of other demonic
creatures from other cultures such as
forms and satires and Greek mythology in
Norse mythology Krampus is believed to
be the son of Hell the daughter of Loki
and keeper of the underworld
the legend of Krampus is part of a
century-old tradition in Germany
December 5th was known as Krampus night
but children would be especially wary
not to attract the attention of the
Beast hoping that come December 6 st.
Nicholas would have left them presents
children would leave out their shoes for
Saint Nicholas who would fill them with
gifts if they had been good he would
place a lump of coal in the shoes of
those who have misbehaved and they would
be later dealt with by Krampus Krampus
laughs or the Krampus run is an annual
festival still celebrated to this day in
Austria and throughout the Alpine region
the tradition itself is thought to be
over 500 years old and individuals would
often dress up as the demon of Christmas
himself wearing heavy coats of fur made
from the hide of sheeps and goats
so they Dorn homes and terrifying masks
in the image of Krampus they roam the
towns and cities with torches and birch
whips and they are usually accompanied
by a st. Nicholas who leads the group
throughout the town where they can be
seen slapping people in the back of
their legs with their whips and switches
they will scare the local children and
sometimes even adults throwing them into
the snow all in the name of fun some
will even go door-to-door visiting
people in their houses and given them
treats and other goodies somewhat of a
reversal to the trick-or-treat tradition
in some parts of Austria before
Christian influenced December was the
month of monsters and ghouls
at first glance
Krampus seems to play the role of the
Christmas villain but he represents far
more than just an evil entity Krampus is
seen to be the counterpart to Saint
Nicholas with good comes bad with light
comes a dark Krampus was often referred
to as the shadow of Saint Nicholas there
are those who still see Krampus as a
symbol of the devil but in modern day
despite still being feared Krampus has
become somewhat of a symbol of
celebration in many cultures I
personally never seen Krampus as a force
of true evil to me Krampus symbolizes
the need for our moral compass to be
balanced there must be rewards and
consequences for the actions we take
if receiving no presents from Santa
Claus is not enough to dissuade the bad
behavior of children then surely a visit
from Krampus will if you've enjoyed this
video then please consider leaving a
thumbs up as it helps promote the video
and allows the channel to grow if
there's anything you'd like to discuss
or have any ideas for future videos then
please let me know in the comment
section as always I've been your host
mythology in fiction explained
[Music]